so let's do a quick recap of what we
talked about last time so we started
talking about GPS
and we said that the GPS is a sensing
technology that specifically enables us
to do localization and some odometry
using signals from satellites that are
orbiting the Earth and by localization
we basically mean to determine the 3D
position of the receiver
and it's useful because if you have a
map then you can use your localization
data to exactly pinpoint your location
on the map okay and odometry remember
it's basically uh information about how
how we're moving so basically you can
think of it as the 3D velocity Vector of
the receiver for instance that's what we
mean by odometry
and uh how does it work at a very high
level at the core of it is this concept
of ranging uh using time of flight
measurements which is a very simple
concept so assume and it's not only GPS
right this is a very very general
concept and you would see it throughout
the class that many other sensors that
we talk about also at the core use this
idea of ranging via time of flight which
is basically you have a transmitter and
a receiver okay and the transmitter
sends some signal right in the case of
the GPS it's an electromagnetic wave
that it transmits and here I'm showing
it as a pulse but it can be a continuous
signal I mean there's very different
ways of doing it but the concept is you
send something and it travels through a
medium at some velocity call it C and
then it reaches the receiver right now
if the transmitter and the receiver have
synchronized clocks and if they have
somehow agreed on and where the signal
was transmitted okay and I haven't told
you how yet but let's just assume that
there's this time t 0 that is known to
the transmitter and the receiver and
they have agreed that at t 0 I'm going
to send you a signal and then the
receiver waits to receive that signal
and some time has passed for this to
travel through the medium and the
receiver checks the clock uh when it
receives it and it sees okay it's t0
plus Tau so Tau must have been the
travel time or the time of flight of the
signal from the transmitter to receiver
and then if the receiver measures Tau
right and then it also the speed of the
travel of that signal through the medium
is known so for instance if it's an
electromagnetic wave in free space we
know exactly what the speed of light is
so you just multiply that time of flight
by the velocity or the speed and that
gives you range so you go from a Time
measurement to a distance measurement so
time and distance are coupled through
this basically velocity here okay
so that's that's again simple concept
but but very foundational to how GPS and
many other sensors work and then uh
how do you use it uh so then the way
it's used specifically for GPS is this
idea of localization via range
measurements so in a simple 2D example
we saw that
if you have two transmitters say two
satellites at two known positions P1 and
P2 okay and in the 2K 2D case these are
two vectors and the 3D case These are 3D
vectors so P1 P2 are known and then the
receiver if it can measure its range or
distance from each of them then the
location of the receiver relative to
each of the transmitters has to be on a
circle which is centered at the position
of the transmitter with the radius that
is equal to the distance from that so
you get one circle around P1 another
circle around P2 and they will intersect
at two points call them A and B so then
the actual position of the receiver has
to be either at a or at B there's still
some ambiguity here and we talked about
different ways that you can disambiguate
for instance if you have more
transmitters if you add one more then
there is be a there's going to be a
third circle and then they would
intersect at just one point that's one
way so add more measurements basically
that will break the ambiguity for you or
if you have some constraints that you
can add to the problem for instance you
know that your receiver is on the
surface of the Earth which is this
ellipsoid and then include that as a
constraint to the problem then you can
also break the ambiguity and determine
the position exactly okay so that's the
core concept or principle of operation
of the GPS
but very specifically for it to work
three things need to happen right so
it's kind of like a three-step process
first uh the receiver needs to as it's
called acquire a number of satellites so
this acquisition step what it means is
that it needs to receive signals from
them and from the signals be able to
find the exact position of the
satellites and how many are needed at
least four so it needs to find at least
four satellites and be able to determine
the exact position so P1 P2 P3 and P4
need to be estimated or determined by
the receiver that's step one then it
needs to find its range to each of these
four satellites using this concept of
time of flight measurements so that's a
step two so find the range to each of
the satellites via the tof principle so
that's four numbers R1 R2 R3 R4 right
that's the second estimation step and
then the third step so now you have the
positions you have the ranges and then
you need to solve this essentially
geometric problem of finding the
intersection of these spheres right the
intersection point which is the position
of your receiver so you would use the uh
positions P1 to P4 and the ranges R1 to
R4 to estimate the receiver position we
call it P sub R which is a three Vector
right we look localizing in 3D so xryr
ZR and remember we said there is a
fourth parameter that needs to be
estimated which is the clock offset Tau
sub D of the receiver with respect to
the GPS reference clock and the reason
there is this Tau sub D is that if we go
back to the time of flight measurement
principle we said that the underlying
assumption here is that the clock of the
transmitter and the receiver are
perfectly synchronized right so when
they agree that I'm going to transmit at
T equals t 0
T equals t 0 is the exact same time for
the transmitter and the receiver in real
world that's never the case it is the
case between the GPS satellites so the
GPS satellite systems these 30 something
satellites that are orbiting the Earth
they have very fancy super well
synchronized clocks between them so
that's kind of like your standard
reference clock system of the GPS but
our receivers our phones our laptops our
car GPS systems or whatever receivers we
have they do not have perfect clocks
these are these cheap
electronic clocks based on oscillators
and things like that so our clock is
always going to be offset from the GPS
reference clock so there's going to be
the time of flight that we measure is
not not just t0 plus T it's a plus Tau
it's t0 plus Tau plus our timing delay
called the taosa D which is the offset
with respect to the reference clock so
for the GPS to work if you do not
account for Tau sub D that's going to go
into our range measurements of course
right so our range becomes instead of
just c times Tau it becomes c times Tau
plus this error term which is c times
Tau d so our ranges would be off and we
saw that if your engines are off then
your position is going to be inaccurate
and it just breaks the system so you
have to also estimate an account for
your timing offset and that's why for at
least four satellites are needed right
because you're estimating four
parameters x y z and Tau so you need
four measurements at least in principle
the the receivers usually try to acquire
as many satellites as they can they
typically work with like six seven or
eight depending on how how many are are
available at the time and then that just
adds more measurements and makes it more
accurate but if if it cannot find at
least four satellites your GPS wouldn't
wouldn't work it will just try to
acquire more and that's uh sometimes in
in challenging uh cases where you do not
have a line of sight to those number of
satellites you might have experienced
that your GPS just takes a very long
time to get you the first position fixed
because it's just trying to find the
four reliable satellites okay so this is
super high level now what we're gonna do
today and the next lecture is we're
going to go deep dive into these three
steps like really really go deep down
and see how each of these work how do
you find their estimate the position of
these satellites that are orbiting the
Earth how do you do actual
time-of-flight measurements to each
satellite and then how do you use these
measurements to estimate your position
and and timing offset okay any questions
no all right let's continue
so uh here's where we are um on this
slide so
um again the receiver needs to uh uh
basically estimate the satellite
locations in orbit and that is
calculated from what is called the
ephemeris data okay I'll tell you what
it is but uh that's that's the
terminology used for it it's called the
ephemeris data and then the ranges or
the time time of flights are calculated
from what is called ranging codes okay
again don't worry if these are not
familiar we're going to talk about it in
in a lot of detail okay before that
let's uh start from a high level
overview of the GPS system so uh this is
uh just a picture showing uh kind of
like the constellation of of the GPS
satellites that orbit the earth and the
first satellite was launched in 1978 and
the system became full fully operational
in 1995 and I've fully operational what
it means is that it it basically started
getting full coverage around the globe
you know with all the good properties
that that we talked about uh uh that
were required of the GPS system it
nominally consists of 24 satellites in
six equally spaced orbital planes so
each color here is is an orbital plane
like this red one for instance and as
you see there's like four uh little dots
on it and those are the nominal
positions of of the satellites and this
is nominal in reality there is more
there's uh 30 something like 36 37 at a
time usually satellites orbiting the
Earth but 24 if it goes below 24 then we
might not get like full coverage and so
that was like the design for at least
like uh 24 satellites orbiting and uh
these are at uh an altitude of 20 200
kilometers above the Earth okay and
they're orbiting the Earth so it's very
important that the location of these
satellites relative to the Earth is is
not constant they're like rotating
around around the earth
um so um here's uh a cool visualization
if I can open it so
um this is cool um so this is here this
this little uh oops uh Red Dot on on the
surface of the Earth that's say your
receiver and it kind of sees over time
as the Earth rotates and the as uh the
satellites are orbiting the Earth those
lines are the line of sights to the
satellite so it kind of shows you like
okay you're you're alternating between
like six seven eight nine ten you know
how many visible satellites you have but
the point is uh at every given time that
number is always above four and and that
was
an important design principle of of the
GPS system
um
and it's not trivial by the way like
it's it's it's very interesting
engineering went into the actual design
of the GPS constellation and how many
orbital planes you want to have how many
satellites you want to have per orbit to
really guarantee uh without launching
too many satellites because these are
very very very expensive right we are
talking like billions of dollars per
satellite uh and and there's like
maintenance for each of them and you
don't want to like blow up the cost of
the the system out of proportion so
Engineers came up with like a minimal
set of satellites with very specific
orbit uh trajectories around the earth
to always guarantee four satellites in
inside it's it's pretty interesting in
that regard okay um so it's it's owned
by the U.S government the GPS system and
operated by the U.S space force now
towards the end of the the chapter we'll
talk about now the GPS is not the only
satellite positioning system different
countries like the European Union has
their own version of it Russia has their
own version of it China Japan India
there's there's different uh basically
satellite Positioning Systems the
principle of operation is exact same and
in fact the the modern receivers use and
acquire satellites for multiple uh uh uh
global positioning system beyond the GPS
and this is called the gnss that we'll
talk about but again we talk about
basically the American version which is
the GPS and it's the the biggest one in
terms of the coverage and the
performance but there's other other
versions of it operated by by other
nations so again it provides accurate
continuous Global 3D position and
velocity information as well as the what
we called the coordinated universal time
which is related to that timing offset
again if you estimate your timing offset
and correct for it then essentially
every clock on every device on earth
that is connected to GPS can be as
accurate and perfectly synchronized with
the GPS reference clock which is this
amazing byproduct I mean we think of GPS
as just a localization technology but
actually the timing technology that
comes is associated with it and the
synchronization across the globe of all
these devices is as important and and as
useful as the positioning capabilities
of it okay another thing that's very
interesting is that essentially because
it's a one-way Communication System the
satellite just broadcasts some signals
and you use them to localize yourself
and synchronize your time it can service
an unlimited number of users there's you
know it's just it's like radio right
it's just broadcast and then you receive
it so you can have as many receivers
there's no interference between the
receivers or congestion of you know
bandwidth because the receivers do not
need to talk to the satellites it's just
one way which is very very interesting
and uh also worth noting is that there
is a worldwide Ground Control and
monitoring network of stations that kind
of communicate with these devices in the
background with these satellites in the
background and monitor their health
their trajectories make sure they're
fully operational so there is a whole
ground section to the GPS also which
almost nobody cares about but it's
really important to maintain and you
know uh make sure uh the the reliability
and and operational condition of the of
the GPS
um also worth noting is that not all the
satellites in the GPS system are the
same there's many different generations
of these satellites now we are at the on
the third generation of the sellers
those are the most modern ones that we
started launching them in late 2010s I
think so these are very modern
satellites but there's still like gen
two different versions of Gen 2 these
are called blocks uh for for some reason
so there's uh as of I think last year
there are seven block two are so block
two is like second generation and R is
for replenishment so it was some
specific version of the hardware there
were seven block two RM for M is for
modernized and we'll talk about what
what we mean by modernization 12 block
2f and just four block three so they are
still launching block three uh GPS
satellites which has some interesting
new capabilities uh so they're kind of
constantly you know upgrading the
hardware launching new satellites adding
cable abilities and and so on and so
forth
some pictures of of the satellites
they're not huge they're just these like
almost Cube looking few meters across uh
things with big solar panels and I think
three of them A B and C these are the
second generation or block two
satellites different versions of the
hardware and then this one is a is the
more modern block 3 satellite
okay so now let's talk about the signals
that these satellites transmit so as we
said the receiver needs to determine two
things or estimate the position of the
satellites and also its range to each
satellite and the satellites transmit
two distinct kind of signals for these
two functions that the receiver needs to
uh do there is ranging signals also
called codes and we'll see why they're
called codes and these are used to
determine satellite to use a range and
there's what we call the navigation
signals so the navigation signals are
like data packets so there's like human
understandable information in them it's
like the internet data packets that you
receive over the internet right so
there's frames and there is you know
different fields within each frame and
subframe and the navigation signals are
used to determine the position of the
satellites okay the ranging signals the
reason they're codes because these are
mathematical codes like this the ranging
codes are not human understandable you
should do some math on them to be able
to extract range and we'll go in in full
depth on what the math is and what these
codes are but the navigation signals you
can interpret them right I mean yes
there's like you need to decode it
correctly and that's the packets but the
the satellite literally tells you here
is where I am at this point in time okay
uh and that's how how it's done okay so
uh more specifically the ranging signals
that are used these are called
pseudorandom noise or PRN
signals or codes and these are binary
sequences if you have not heard of PRN
no worries we'll again uh fully fully in
depth talk about them and and tell you
what they are and why they're
interesting uh what's important and
today we'll talk a little about it is
that there's different different ranging
codes that the satellites determine uh
transmit there's like actually there's a
whole bunch of them and we'll talk about
them and and there's there's reasons why
not just one so there's for instance a
ranging code that is for civilian
applications then there's another
ranging code which is more accurate for
military applications and they're very
distinct and there's different ranging
codes on different frequencies and then
there's the Legacy the ones which were
pre-2000 and then there's some Modern
codes that are that are transmitted the
principle of operation between like the
military version and the civilian
version and the legacy codes and the
modern codes exact same right but there
is some functional differences but you
know the math and the physics is exact
same so
um
that's just uh worth noting and uh the
type of modulation that is used for most
of these codes as well as the navigation
signals is just binary phase shifting
bpsk modulation again if you're not
familiar with this I'll describe it for
you and uh both in phase and quadrature
components of the carrier are used and
typically modulated over and in terms of
the carrier frequency that the GPS uses
there's five distinct frequency bands
they're all between one and two
gigahertz but there's five different
channels that all these GPS satellites
use for for communicating both the
ranging signals and the navigation
signals and you might ask okay so
there's
something between like 24 at least to 30
something satellites transmitting all
these different types of signals there's
like navigation signals there's ranging
codes there's different flavors of
ranging codes so how do we do it on just
five frequencies without these
interfering with each other and the
concept that is used is called code
division multiple access or CDMA and
again if you're not familiar with this
that's okay we'll uh talk about it but
the core idea here is that
um the signals are mathematically
orthogonal to each other although
they're transmitted on the same
frequency they are orthogonal and just
like orthogonal vectors you can you know
distinguish them these signals also you
can use this principle of orthogonality
and distinguish the signals that you're
receiving from different satellites
although they're all coming on the same
frequency
okay let's have a quick look there
that's like an idealized version of
signal model
so here this sft
is the signal that uh the the satellite
transmits and as I said it has two
components so there's an in-phase
component to it which is this first term
and then there's a quadrature component
okay this should be familiar from uh
communication Theory so each of them has
basically this is the carrier which is
just a oscillatory signal a cosine of 2
pi times the carrier frequency F Sub C
plus some phase phases we don't care the
receiver really doesn't care it's just
for completeness in the model we include
that and then the quadrature component
same thing it's just a sign instead of a
cosine and that's how you get the
orthogonality between your uh in phase
and quadrature because the sine and the
cosine at the same frequency those are
orthogonal functions then there's a
bunch of things multiplying each of
these so first term this root
root 2 p is just a number that's kind of
like the power that you put in the in
phase and the quadrature components um
so so that's just the power and then
what's really important to us is these
two signals there's an X and there's a d
both multiplying and they carry or
modulating the carrier the x is uh the
ranging code
okay and then the D is the navigation
signal
so um again just uh here's is the
summary of of what I just said and for
now just assume uh that the X and the D
these are just uh binary uh phase
modulated signals so as streams so each
we start from a binary stream so let's
say your X of t
it's just some code binary code so just
zero zero one one zero whatever right
it's a series of bits that's a code and
then uh the way the bpsk modulation
works is that uh wherever you have a bit
zero you map it to a phase of zero so
that's e to the J zero or uh plus one
and then wherever your bit is minus one
the modulation is e to the J Pi so you
either at a phase of zero or a phase of
Pi so that's why it's binary uh phase
shift keying which is equal to -1 so
basically the actual modulated version
of that X of T becomes uh according to
this becomes plus one plus one minus one
minus one plus one plus one and so on
and then this stream is is modulating
the carrier so the carrier is basically
getting multiplied by a stream of plus
ones or minus ones which is the binary
modulation same for the DI okay that
also is binary phase shift key modulated
now you might ask well how do we because
at the receiver we need to decouple
what's the ranging code and what's the
navigation signal and if both of these
are just plus minus ones that are
multiplied by each other how do we
distinguish and I'll tell you about it
it's actually a very simple principle
but for now just bear with me we'll get
back to that now um note that this is
kind of like the idealized sigma model
in reality and the signal model is is
more complicated because we are not here
a modeling effects like the fact that as
I said there's multiple codes uh being
transmitted for ranging for instance we
haven't modeled the noise we haven't
model interferences effects like Doppler
shift timing Jitter or non-linear FX all
of those are kind of factored out it's
fine again with this idealized signal
model we can fully understand and
analyze how the GPS works but if you're
interested some parts of the slides as
you see there's Piper links and these
are fully optional reads if you are
interested for instance this one takes
you to this website gnss software
defined radio which is this open source
community of people
working on GPS and this one has like the
full
full-blown GPS signal model if you're
interested these are optional reads for
you
okay back to
our discussion any questions so far
about the signal model and this idea of
ranging versus navigation signals again
I know this is right now it's super
vague
it might borderline not even fully make
sense we'll clarify all of this right so
there's a lot to unpack here but for now
at least the high level there's ranging
codes and there is navigation signals
and these are binary phase shift key
modulated onto the end phase and the
quadrature components of a carrier at a
frequency F Sub C
if this makes sense we should continue
but again please I I really really
request at any point if things don't
make sense stop me and just flat out
tell me that did not make any sense
right I owe it to you to make sure
things make sense and again there's a
lot here that that we discussed so for
sure at some point for each of you some
stuff should not make sense so just to
stop me right there and and uh let's
let's clarify it
Okay so
here's a high level table showing so as
I said there is five different frequency
bands for the GPS signals and this is a
high level table kind of showing uh how
these frequencies are used
so the frequencies are called L1 on to
L5
and these are the exact frequencies of
each these are fixed right these are
fixed the receivers know them and the
the GPS satellites never changed the
frequencies that they use
and then for each there is uh basically
in phase and and quadrature components
being used and here you have two columns
one says Legacy user usage and one says
modernize usage so what this is is that
when GPS has started up till the year
uh the signals that was transmitted by
the GPS satellites uh those are called
Legacy signals and then in year 2000
there was this big modernization that
happened for the GPS and we will talk
about it and then what happened then is
that a whole bunch of new ranging
signals and navigation uh signals were
introduced or added to the GPS system
and there were some Hardware upgrades a
lot of uh algorithm and and code
upgrades and that's what is the
modernized uh GPS basically and we will
talk about both the the Legacy and the
modernized but for let's look at the
Legacy for now so as you see in the
Legacy uh the the the the last three
frequencies weren't even used for
navigation so L4 and L5 were flat out
not used L3 was just used for nuclear
detonation signals not related to us and
there were two
signals transmitted on L1 one is called
py and the other one is CA I'm sorry the
notation makes absolute no sense here
we'll I'll try to clarify it but for
some reason when that they were kind of
like naming these ranging signals they
they came up with these weird type of
notation but we'll clarify it the P is
for for military use and the C is for
civilian use these are two the names of
the two ranging signals and then on L2
they were also transmitting the the py
and nothing on the quadrature right so
the military in Legacy we had two
frequencies for military ranging and
just one frequency for civilian and then
for modernize as you see here A whole
bunch of new stuff added got added I'll
talk about these uh in a bit but L3 is
still not used for it's kind of reserved
for some research applications and
things like that but not used for
civilian or military uh localization uh
L5 also is as uh being a studies for
some future you know upgrades to the to
the GPS system and then L5 is actually
used so this is where we are with the
GPS signals today okay now the next
five or so minutes I'm gonna talk about
all these different codes which would be
a
nomenclature here and it's it's a little
boring I'm sorry but it's important I
think you should at least high level
know uh what these are I'll I'll go
quickly because there's like a lot of
numbers that uh it's the kind of a thing
that later in your work if you need to
know the specifics of the ca code this
could be your go-to place that go dig up
your e259 lecture notes and find out
what these are but high level each each
code so start with the ca so we're
talking about Legacy GPS ranging codes
not the navigation messages yet CA
stands for course acquisition code and
again this was a legacy GPS signal still
being transmitted today so today we're
transmitting the modernized signals
Legacy signals still being transmitted
and relevant today so it's what we call
a short code modulated at
1.023mh bits per second
and it repeats every one millisecond so
what what the way these ranging codes
work is that it's it's this binary
sequence and it's modulated at some uh
uh uh baud rate so in in this case 1.023
megabits per second and then it just
repeats so it's just periodically over
and over and over again same exact same
uh uh uh code is is being transmitted
and that's the case for every type of
ranging codes these range encodes are
periodic signals that are just over and
over transmitted so this one repeats
every one millisecond which means at
this bits per second you get exactly 10
023 code bits right about bits I mean
these zeros and ones right those are the
bits uh in they're also called chips so
and you would see I'll use the two terms
kind of interchangeably so bits and
chips again um
if this is
say your course acquisition code
I'm just going to draw the waveform for
it
okay
pre-modulation is just zeros and ones
right so you have like zero one zero
zero zero one zero one and so on each of
these pulses
is called a chip
so that's what we mean by digits and
then depending on your sampling rate you
might have just like one sample per chip
if you digitize it or if you sample
faster you might have multiple samples
per chip but the chip is just one of
these pulses or or one of the bits in
the underlying mathematical code okay
and um
each of the satellites
the 30-something satellites in orbit
uses a unique CA code okay and that's
very very important so the code
transmitted by each satellite they all
have the same number of chips they're
all modulated over the same frequency at
the same baud rate but the actual you
know that bit stream of zero one zero
zero zero is is unique for each
satellite and that's very and that's how
you distinguish it that idea of code
division multiple access that I set is
actually here they use unique codes and
these codes are orthogonal to each other
now orthogonal you might ask how exactly
like what do we mean by orthogonality
because these are not exactly vectors
that you know you can do an inner
product between I'll clarify what
orthogonality means but for now the
concept is that each satellite transmits
a unique CA code and always that code
they never change their codes it's part
of the GPS's standard that satellite
block 2f number 3 transmits this very
specific code and the receivers know
that they have like this table hard
coded of the codes associated with every
satellite and it's as I said broadcast
on the L1 frequency band I found the
first typo here
highlighted to
correct it later
and please let me know as you find like
typos and inconsistencies in the lecture
notes so I can correct them and it's for
civilian use okay py uh it's it's called
the Precision code P4 Precision I'm not
going to spend too much time on it it's
faster by a factor of 10 so 10.23
megabits per second it's also much much
much longer than the than the ca code I
mean look here CA code was one
millisecond this one repeats every 37
weeks okay so I know like something like
12 orders of magnitude longer so because
it's so long each side the satellites
cannot store the whole thing I mean it's
just too too much memory for these
satellites I mean it's it's like 10 to
the 14 chips so what they did instead is
they've they've broken it into segments
and each satellite
transmits a one week long segment of the
four
py code so unlike the ca where it's a
short code and each satellite has its
own code unique to make py unique
between these two satellites they they
took this giant 37 week long code and
then they chopped it into one week long
sections and every satellite repeatedly
transmits a one week long section of the
py code uh it's uh it's encrypted so
there's this cryptographic W code that
is xored with uh picot and that's why
it's called py so that's like the coded
or a version of the p and it's
supposedly robust to interference and
spoofing and as I said it's broadcast in
both L1 and L2 frequency bands
simultaneously for from each satellite
as for military use so it's close to the
public like our devices our phones
laptops they cannot uh
acquire or use the py code for ranging
applications it's only open to the
military and that's because this W code
that is is used for encryption is only
known for military devices
um
okay any questions about yes
[Music]
then what is that on the receiver side
like the user how to know the range of
uh oh we'll get to that so so for now
that's a great question so the question
was okay so the satellites are
transmitting these codes which is these
binary bit streams how does the receiver
use them to to do time of flight ranging
and we'll get to that that's a big big
part of this uh this chapter in the
course that okay how do you go from this
bit stream to time of flight and then
convert that to to range great question
but bear with me for now we're just you
know familiarizing ourselves with like
different codes and the terminology but
we'll get to the math soon that's why
this is the boring part I want to like I
get this over with quickly so we get to
the interesting stuff
okay and now
there's there's two oh yes questions
yeah obviously
the area is 37 weeks
um
how's that immediately useful someone
instructors receiving a signal from
that's a great question so uh and uh I
was told that I should repeat the
question so people watching the videos
know what the question was so the
question was uh it's it's a 37 week long
say code or for each satellite it's one
week long right so how is it useful like
should the receiver wait for an entire
week to receive one period of this code
and then use ranging I mean that's
that's useless great question uh and uh
no they do not need the full code so the
way the receivers operate for the py
code is that they can
operate on short sections of the code so
they don't need to to they actually wait
and acquire the minimum amount that
gives them enough signal to noise ratio
that they can use for uh ranging and
that's how it operates the py code
because again it's for military
um it's a lot is not known to the public
about it so like the exact like the
exact code of course is unknown but also
some of the details of like how exactly
they are like that what is say the
minimum acquisition time that they need
to do one position fix is not exactly
known but if I were to guess it would be
at most equal to the one millisecond for
the ca code or possibly even less okay
so the fact that it's it's just long uh
it's just helps them in the cases where
the signal is very weak then you can
just integrate or acquire a longer piece
of this code to boost your SNR and then
and then you do acquisition so they have
this trade-off knob of uh either if when
the signals are strong just do very
short Acquisitions and and uh do do
ranging with that when the signal is
very weak just capture a longer section
of this week-long signal and then do uh
ranging with that if it makes sense
okay great question
uh all right let's talk about the Legacy
uh navigation signal
and the Legacy navigation signal uh it's
called lnaf L4 Legacy now for navigation
and this as I said these are human
understandable signals so these are no
not like ranging cozies like
mathematical bit streams these are like
data packets on the internet and it it
contains three key pieces of information
uh the the lnav signals one is the GPS
date and time uh and the satellite
status so the status satellite says oh
I'm healthy I'm doing fine you can trust
this or when there's some fault
condition happening they flag some bits
so the receiver knows oh this satellite
is you know out of order I should not
use it for ranging and then GPS date and
time is just a date and time when the
packet is leaving or being transmitted
they just time stamp it with the GPS
data and time then there's two other
pieces of information one called the
ephemeris and one called The Almanac
ephemeris is very important to us as
we'll see because the femoris is
essentially the precise location of the
transmitting satellite at the time that
it's transmitting the signal okay so the
satellite tells you the satellite is
aware of their position with respect to
to the Earth and they tell you that at
this time that I'm sending you the
signal this is my exact position
relative to the earth now we'll see the
way they send it
um for for uh very good reasons it's not
like XYZ location so they basically
describe their trajectory to you not
their exact position because again the
Earth is rotating these satellites are
orbiting the Earth so by the time the
signal receives you the satellite has
moved right and you sometimes need to
account for that so when you're doing
your ranging so instead of sending you
an actual position they describe their
trajectory and and we'll see how how
it's done it's very interesting and then
the almanac is basically the information
about the rest of the satellites in in
the in the constellation and it tells
you it's very low resolution information
so roughly tells you like
where the other satellites are orbiting
and you know are they healthy or not
it's just used to you know kind of high
level check what the status of the GPS
satellites are
as we receive them
now
I want to clarify one thing that I
pointed out later which is that okay so
we have ranging codes and we have
navigation signals and both of these are
modulating the exact same carrier okay
so how does the receiver distinguish
these if you just multiply two of these
binary sequences so if I take this so if
that's my X of t
right
and then if I have my D of T which is
the LNF say signal
right so my X of T is let's say the
course acquisition my DFT is lnav
another a binary stream right
whatever
zero one one I mean the specifics
doesn't matter but if I just multiply X
of T times D of t
and just send that to the receiver how
does the receiver demultiplex and
because the receiver needs to
separate out what's X of T and what's D
of T because X is used for range and D
as we said it has for instance the
ephemeris data in it and it uses D to
find the position of the satellite it
uses X to find the range to the
satellite so it needs to demultiplex
those but if I just multiply these out
you cannot go back right so
multiplication so how does that work
it's actually very simple the way it
works is that
as you see here the uh the baud rate or
the bit rate of these two signals is
vastly different so your course
acquisition code which is actually the
slowest code that we send as I said is
that
1.023 megabits per second okay and then
the L map is only at 50 bits per second
right so one bit of the lnav takes what
1 over 50 20 milliseconds right so it's
for for a whole duration of 20
milliseconds your lnav is just either at
one or zero or the binary modulated
version is at plus one or minus one
right which is equal to 20 full CA codes
right so basically just by looking at
different time scales the receiver can
distinguish the lnav from the ca like if
if you if you just take a one second
time window one millisecond time window
during that you can ignore the D of T
because that's just the constant and the
variations that are fast are just your
course acquisition code
and the other way around if you look at
like very very long time scales then you
can you can figure out what the lnap
message is so that's how uh basically
it's done but this is how the
transmitter basically uh combines the
two so you modular to add or xor and the
the the two binary sequences and then
just use one bpsk modulator
um to to transmit this is exactly
mathematically by the way equal to what
we had a few slides before so what you
get out of the modulator this broadcast
signal here is actually X of t
times D of t
but where your X and D if you
individually bpsk modulate them so if
you make your x50 go from 0 1 to plus
minus one
and also your DFT modulated to plus
minus one and then multiply them that's
exactly what you get out of this module
this is another way I mean different
representation same math you can either
xor them and then just use one modulator
or individually modulate them and then
multiply the outputs of the two
modulators exact same in practice
usually this is the implementation
any yes
what information is being conveyed
through the course acquisition code what
information uh so okay question what
information is being conveyed over the
ca or course acquisition code so there
is no human understandable information
it's just a binary sequence seemingly
random
of zeros and ones
okay and that's why it's called a
pseudo-random noise PRM sequence and we
will see how
from this pseudorandom sequence of zeros
and ones you can actually extract
time-of-flight information and then
convert that to range so so the ca again
there's no you know human understandable
information in it but mathematically
it's designed such that with some
mathematical operation you can extract
range time of flight and then range okay
again it's very vague right now but
we'll get to it we'll get to very
specific like mathematical description
and LNF is just human readable right
it's literally you know
numbers and you know things that that
one can understand
okay
um any other questions no all right so
uh let's quickly talk about this
modernization that I told you about so
uh modernization GPS modernization was
just this major major overhaul of the
GPS system across the board from the
hardware to the algorithms the codes
that were sent what frequencies were
used ground systems satellites all of it
was just went uh through this big
modernization effort which was one of
the best things technology wise that the
U.S I think government ever did which
was uh basically they authorized this
modernization effort it happened in year
2000 and it's it's also referred to as
gps3 so 3rd gen GPS is this modern GPS
system so again the new ground stations
new satellites new civil and Military
both navigation signals and also ranging
codes
and for instance one of the big things
that was added was uh forward error
correction which really helps in cases
where you have weak signals if you have
forward error correction you can recover
and I'll talk about the the what new
civilian and Military codes were added
but possibly the most important thing
that happened as part of the GPS
modernization was the end of what was
called The Selective availability or
essay so what selective availability was
was that
pre-2000 for civilian applications the
GPS signals were intentionally corrupted
so there was some Jitter added to the
GPS clock that was used for civilian
applications and
basically that was done such that the
civilian GPS was not super accurate
because the government was not sure what
types of applications people would do
with this technology remember this was a
very new technology and the government
was being conservative with the civilian
use of it so they were intentionally you
know messing with the GPS signals by
this thing called The Selective
availability and the GPS really by
today's a standard
pre-2000 GPS for civilian applications
was useless it was this super coarse you
know you could roughly tell I'm like
within these five blocks of the town so
you could not do things like you know
Google Maps or anything really useful
with it at 2000 the government agreed
that okay let's end selective
availability we are going to make the
civilian GPS almost as accurate as the
military interestingly as we'll see and
then that really was this really really
good thing that happened and then that
blew up these applications that we see
around us today where GPS is extremely
extremely useful to the point that even
like indoors sometimes in a big building
you can use your GPS to navigate around
and the the essay availability so it was
turned off so disabled and all the
satellites in orbit at the same time in
year 2000 and the block three satellites
these new satellites that are being
launched now they don't even have that
capability so for good they killed which
is which is very very nice
okay
a little more boring stuff I want to
quickly tell you about these modern
signals that uh got introduced after
year 2000 so there's a bunch of new
ranging signals and a bunch of new
navigation uh signals that were
introduced specifically for ranging
signals three new uh ranging codes for
civilian applications were introduced
called L2 l2c l1c and L5 and one new
military ranging code was introduced and
a few different
Navigation signals were introduced again
let's not spend too much time on this
because it's it's really just the specs
not really quite relevant it's it's I
included these for completeness but
there's an l2c which is called the
second civilian signals as the name
suggests this one is transmitted on the
L2 frequency band contains two different
codes
that are multiplexed on the on the same
frequency called civil moderate and
civil long codes okay and these are
Multiplex at 1.023 megabits per second
uh one is at 20 millisecond long code
the other one is 1.5 second long cook
okay now at this point you might have
seen a couple of interesting things one
is that all the codes we've talked about
in terms of the bitrate there are some
multiple of 10 23 right so we had like
ca at 1.023 megabits per second then
there was a py at 10.23 which is
interestingly
2 to the 10 minus 1 and that's not a
coincidence we'll see why that's the one
of the magic numbers uh of these number
of bits so the the power of two minus
one is really deeply rooted into the
mathematics of how these ranging codes
work and we'll talk about that but these
are not you know arbitrarily decided
these are determined by the mathematics
of how these ranging codes work uh the
other one is that as you see the main
difference between these codes is uh
well there's there's two things one is
how fast they are in terms of the bits
per second right like the military code
was 10 times faster than the course
acquisition code these l2c is almost the
same speed and then there's how long
they are right so there's there's two
factors for for each code and again
later we'll see both of these are
important for uh basically the accuracy
of how accurately you can determine your
range to the satellite and also the
length of of the code so that's what the
speed faster codes are typically more
accurate you can find your range more
accurately and then the length of the
code as I briefly mentioned helps you
with longer integration times which
means when the signal is weak a longer
code helps you do ranging because you
have more signal to work with you can
integrate it for longer and recover
signal out of noise
um okay and that's why you have these
different so there's like the Civil
moderate signal which is only 10 230
chips and then there's the Civil long
code which is like hundreds of thousands
of chips so the longer one although it's
at the same chip rate so accuracy wise
it's the same but it helps you when the
signal is weak because you have more of
these chips to work with to recover
again each satellite uses unique codes
that are orthogonal and this has almost
3 DB higher SNR than the course
acquisition code at 2.3 DB less power so
it's it's quite uh quite a lot better in
terms of SNR capabilities and as of two
years ago there were 23 GPS satellites
that where the the l2c code was enabled
on them they tend to not uh when when it
comes to these big upgrades they tend to
not flip the switch on all satellites at
the same time they kind of like do it uh
over as a number of years just to make
sure you know there's no glitches they
don't want to like jam everybody's GPS
at the same time or something like that
they kind of are conservative with that
so it takes years although like the
modernization was approved in 2000 it's
still not these new signals are not
available on all all satellites also not
all receivers yet support them so
chances are many of the especially
cheaper GPS receivers we use today
they're still working with the Legacy
signals because those signals are still
transmitted and they're easier to to
work with Okay then there's a third
civilian signal called L5 same story
again it it's uh two different codes
transmitted on the in-phase and
quadrature components of the L5 carrier
these are also a 10.23 megabits per
second one millisecond long like the ca
code and there is uh basically some
synchronization sequence also added to
them to help the receiver more easily
synchronize their times to the to the
GPS
uh and then these also have uh uh 10x
more bandwidth 3db higher power and as
of last year this was broadcast from 17
GPS satellites okay and just now we're
seeing some consumer devices uh using uh
the L5 code what's very important what
the L5 code is that it has very very
good SNR so it's good for uh basically a
secure and robust localization for
safety of life applications so people
for instance who do extreme sports
people who go like mountain climbing or
they go like hiking in very remote areas
they usually have these fancier GPS
devices with them which are L5 enabled
because those are the ones that can save
your life in very remote applications
where GPS reception could be pretty poor
so that's important and just now as of
like last year or so I've seen a few
more like cheaper consumer grade devices
that claim their L5 enabled which is
very interesting
um
okay and then there's the fourth
civilian signal l1c this is uh uh
transmitted on the L1 carrier as the
name suggests kind of like the L5 this
is also two codes on modulated on the
inq uh components of the carrier uh both
are 10 milliseconds long same number of
chips uh what's different about the l1c
it it uses a different type of
modulation so it's not binary phase
shift keyed it's some different type of
modulation which is called binary offset
carrier or boc and again you see these
are like slide variations they're doing
on these codes each adds like a benefit
in a certain use case some are good for
low S and R cases some have better
accuracy for ranging again the boc is is
more energy efficient you know it's it's
just these uh slight variations that are
they're doing to different modern codes
just to ensure you know more
availability more universality across
you know use cases cross locations
across devices that's basically the idea
but underlying like if you abstract out
all the little details of like what the
code is called and what exact modulation
is used and go down to the core
mathematical principle of how these
operate as we'll see they're exactly the
same identical so we will just look at
the ca basically because everything else
is identical to that
okay and there's a new military code
called M there's absolutely almost
nothing known about it uh except that
it's it's at uh 5.1 megabits per second
boc modulated and it has a new
um um uh navigation signal associated
with it called mnaf and for military and
it's broadcast on L1 and L2 frequencies
um other than that there's really really
not much known about the amcode one
interesting thing uh with the m code is
that so the way these satellites
broadcast their signals is
um
they have antennas that are very uh wide
in terms of their beam so if this is the
Earth and this is your little
GPS satellite
orbiting
part of my bad drawing
um so generally the antennas they have
because they want to have as much
coverage as possible so they have this
super wide antenna patterns that kind of
like cover
the as much surface as is visible to
them on the earth so they are very wide
now what they did with the block 3
satellites for the M code they have an
additional antenna which I can do kind
of like a much tighter localized uh beam
transmit just for the M code so it's
almost like a separate
antenna that does that and this one can
like
be
much more localized which means it would
have a much higher power density per
area which means much higher SNR so what
they can do is I think they can boost
the SNR but yeah by 20 DB which is a
factor of a hundred it's a lot for
military applications in in very
localized areas which is of course a
huge huge military advantage that that
the US military has okay and then
um there's as I said new navigation
signals also as part of the GPS
modernization
the core idea is the same so the
navigation signals same information they
send you the GPS time there's an
ephemeris which tells you where the GPS
is or the orbit trajectory of the GPS
satellite and then there is an almanac
which tells you the status of the rest
of the satellites in orbit but the
modern ones again they're better they
have like error correction
uh they are there's there's some changes
or some upgrades to the data structure
so they're packet based instead of frame
based
um
honestly I don't know why that's better
but apparently it's better and uh
also for instance the the almanac now
supports up to 64 satellites so in case
later they decide to put much more GPS
satellites in orbit the almanac data
frame has now the capability of
providing the status of up to 64
satellites
and uh
there is also a synap 2 again another
navigation signal for civilian use
modulated onto the l1c code all of these
are very very very similar slide
variations in terms of like what type of
error correction coding they're using or
what is the exact bit rate but in
principle they're all transmitting the
same information which enables you to
determine most importantly the location
of the satellite but also you know
information about the rest of the
constellation and the GPS time and so on
and so forth and then there is a Amna
for military navigation signal we don't
know any details except that it is
Packet based and uses some type of
forward error correction
okay
enough boring stuff uh any questions
no again you don't need to like remember
or know any of these details it's kind
of a thing that I wanted you to kind of
like go through it once so these terms
at least are familiar so if you hear
like oh there's like l2c and uh coding
signal then you say oh yeah I've heard
of it I think I know what you're talking
about but uh mostly for reference so if
the specific thing you're working on I
don't know if you're working on some
next-gen GPS receiver or some other
project then you can refer to these and
kind of like get the specifics of these
ranging codes that that you want okay
this is the same table we saw before but
hopefully at least these names are
familiar to you so as you see in now if
you look at the modernized one L1 is
pretty busy we are transmitting a lot of
stuff on the L1 so there's still the
Legacy military py code there's a modern
military code there's the l1c uh D which
is the data part of the l1c under in
phase and then on the quadrature of L1
we have the Legacy CA code for civilian
and then the modern L1 uh also for
civilian L2 also kind of not as busy but
there's a bunch of things there's of the
in phase is military only Legacy and the
modern and the quadrature is for
civilian only and then L3 L4 again as I
said they're not used for localization
but they're reserved for some other
applications and then L5 purely for
civilian use both in phase and
quadrature and also it's important for
like those safety of Life type
applications it has the best SNR
capabilities and some safety features
associated with it um
I think it's also good to take a look at
what the power spectral densities of
these signals look like so the way to
look at these plots here let's look at
just this one top left one so this is
showing
um as a function of frequency the power
of these different coding signals that
are modulated onto the L1 carrier right
so the way to read this is there's two
planes one here the the the the the
vertical plane is sort of your uh um say
I Channel or in Phase Channel and then
the horizontal one is your quadrature
channel and then this axis here is
frequency so zero is the center
frequency around carrier so this one is
for L1 so what zero really is it's not
DC it's like the center L1 frequency and
then around it as you see we're rough
using about a 30 megahertz bandwidth
right plus minus 15 that's how much
bandwidth we're roughly using and each
color corresponds to a different code
that's being transmitted say on L1 and
let's there's some interesting
properties I think let's just inspect
two of them so if you look at this this
darker green one uh that's our CA code
right
and if you remember it's it's a slow
it's one of this or actually the slowest
code at one one megabit per second and
as you might remember from uh signal
process singular communication courses
signals slower signals don't have have
less bandwidth right so the how fast you
uh the bit rate of your signal that
directly correlates with the bandwidth
and as you see the green one it's kind
of narrow it has like this very narrow
main Peak which is actually just around
one one Mega is one to two megahertz and
then it has a bunch of side lobes right
around it quite a bit down in terms of
power
and if you compare that to one of the
fast codes say pick your py code this
one here which is this uh Brown darker
brown color py code if you remember that
was 10 times faster right that was
modulated at 10 megabits per second and
here you see the main lobe of the py
code is much much wider than the ca so
at least qualitatively these make sense
as you make your code faster you it
takes up more bandwidth or takes up more
more Spectrum
I I should probably have used this one
uh because it's less busy but same idea
again here you have your M code that is
pretty wide right because that's a fast
code and then you have your l2c code
also a slow code and that's the main
Peak is much much narrower but again
this is just qualitatively use you see
how the spectrum is used and how much
power and bandwidth each of these codes
are are taking on different frequencies
so we have L1 we have L2 and we have L5
here which is uh the the less least
cluttered I would say and then L3 L4 are
not using for ranging as of now so
that's why there's no no picture for
that
questions
no okay so let's continue
um
there is uh two different types of GPS
Services
which directly relates to like these uh
ranging and uh um navigation signals
that we talked about one is called PPS
or precise positioning service so this
is enabled this is military stuff right
so it's enabled the ranging is done with
the military codes which is either py or
the modern version that is the m code
and then the navigation of it uses the
military again either the modern mnav or
the Legacy LNF for for military and this
is highly encrypted and only authorized
military devices can use it and has all
sorts of you know safety military grade
features like anti-spoofing and so on
and so forth and the nominal accuracy of
it is two to nine meters so that's your
localization accuracy so you can
localize yourself within a a
circle or a sphere of a radius that is
two to nine meters okay so it's it's
pretty good but also I should note that
it varies a lot so GPS accuracy there's
a lot of different factors that affect
your signal quality and It ultimately
affect the localization accuracy so
these are nominal numbers in worst case
conditions it might be 10 times worse
than this in absolute best case
conditions it can be even centimeter
accurate okay so it really really
depends on strength of the signal and a
number of other effects that that we'll
talk about then there is the standard
positioning service which is all what
all the civilian devices use and this as
we said it can use any of the civilian
codes for ranging
I think today probably most devices
still use the course acquisition the
Legacy signal but now we're
transitioning to either of these L2 L5
L1 and then it uses either the synap or
the Legacy Elna for
navigation messages it's open to the
public so these days you can even do
like a DIY project and pretty much build
your GPS receiver from scratch it
becomes a very big project actually but
it's
could be fun but every detail of the
navig of the civilian stuff is known
from the detail of the codes the
communication details packages the error
correction because it's all very well
documented so you can build your own
thing and the accuracy of five to ten
meters
so what's very interesting here is if
you
before I learned about all this my
expectation was or I was always under
the assumption that the military stuff
is much much more accurate than the
civilian it's not the case actually the
accuracies are Ballpark the same uh for
both and this is thanks to by the way
turning off the selective availability
before that civilian was much worse but
now uh ballpark the same so why have the
distinction well the military stuff has
a bunch of extra features uh that that's
why it's important so for instance the
ephemeris updates which tells you where
the satellite is come much more rapidly
for the military GPS or that precise
positioning it's more robust to some of
these effects that degrade the GPS
signal quality one of them for instance
being the ionospheric delay so
ionosphere is one of these atmospheric
layers above the Earth and it's uh
pretty uh notoriously uh uh Troublesome
for GPS signals because uh the the
frequency of the the GPS signals lies in
a band where inside by the ionosphere
the the speed of light can change
significantly so there is this unknown
delay if we go back to our
time-of-flight principle uh one of the
underlying assumptions was that this C
is constant right but it's not actually
constant because the medium changes you
know you go through different layers of
the atmospheres especially the
ionosphere depending on the incidence
angle can cause some additional delays
in your GPS signal which translates to
range accuracy inaccuracies and
ultimately positional inaccuracies now
the military grade GPS it's much more
robust for instance to this effect right
there's as I said there's encryption
anti-spoofing so you cannot you know
spoof it easily but at the end of the
day remember that
civilian GPS and Military GPS nominally
they are exactly the same accuracy which
is a few meters that's that's what you
can you can expect now
um
regarding the accuracy like is it good
enough or not really depends on your
application right of course I think we
can we can all agree that GPS is
extremely extremely useful right uh both
for human applications and for robotics
um but uh it's not enough like the level
of localization accuracy that you get
from a GPS receiver it kind of like
globally roughly positions you on a map
like you can know you're at roughly this
intersection you know in a city or
around some Block in a town but if you
were to for instance
use only this
to fully automate your robot's movement
it's not enough right so it kind of
gives you a global as the name suggests
it works globally that's the amazing
thing about it uh and uh globally puts
you on the map but you still need much
much much more accurate uh localized uh
or local measurements with other sensors
to further narrow down your location in
accuracy from a few meters down to a few
centimeters possibly or even millimeters
it really depends on what the
application is but if you're in you know
very tight spaces and your robot needs
to like navigate really intricate
structures you need much better than a
few meters so that's where this idea of
for instance Sensor Fusion becomes
important and and that's why you need a
variety of sensors each has its own
unique capabilities but ultimately you
want to you know combine what you get
from all these different sensors to
really get to what you need for your
specific application
okay once questions
no all right we have a couple of minutes
I just want to set up the discussion for
um next time which is uh we're gonna now
talk about you know the actual math and
physics of GPS starting with the
satellite orbits so
um again the first step as we said is
that your receiver needs to find the
exact location of each of these GPS
satellites that are orbiting the Earth
and uh
in a way the satellite tells you where
they are right but you still need to do
quite a bit of math to convert that
information which is what we call the
ephemeris which is part of the
navigation message to the exact location
of the satellite and it involves you
know you have to have a model of what
the this orbital trajectory looks like
which usually it's it's modeled by uh
not usually always it's modeled by a a
an elliptical trajectory
but this needs to be done very very very
accurately so it's actually a pretty
challenging problem you have this
satellite 20 000 kilometers above you
going at very high speeds you're on
Earth that's rotating there's a variety
of forces that affect the satellite from
Earth's gravitational force there is
solar radiations
there is
the emission of different gases from the
saddle light that can you know change
its trajectory so there's all sorts of
different effects that make this
trajectory not be a perfect ellipse and
you receive this very very slow message
remember the uh navigation messages are
transmitted at 50 bits per second so it
can take minutes to receive enough
information of like one ephemeris you
know data point so that that's where a
lot of brilliant engineering has been
done such that with as such a slow
Communication channel on the on the
navigation signals you can still super
accurately and very quickly track the
exact position of the satellite so
that's the what we'll discuss next time